[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM BEDER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Sam Beder,
and I'm a product manager
on Android Things.
Today, I'm going to
talk to you about Google
services on Android
Things, and how
adding these services
to your device
can unlock your
device's potential.
What I really want to
convince you of today
is not only is integrating
Google services on Android
Things really, really easy
and really, really seamless,
but it can make a huge
difference in the use cases
that you can put on your device
as well as for your end users.
And I know this year, we have
many sessions on Android Things
as well as demos in
the sandbox area,
and code labs to learn
more about what's
possible on Android Things.
I also know that many of you
are coming to this session
already with ideas
of devices that you
want to make on Android Things
or for IoT devices in general.
And I want to show you today
all the compelling use cases
that you can get when you
integrate some of these Google
services.
So I'm going to go through
a number of services today.
First, I'm going to talk about
Google Play services, which
includes a whole suite of
tools such as the mobile Vision
APIs, location services,
as well as Firebase.
After that, I'm going to dive
into Firebase in a little bit
more detail to show
you how the real time
database that
Firebase provides can
allow you to publish
and persist data
and events in interesting ways.
After that, I'm going
go into TensorFlow,
and how TensorFlow--
we think-- is the
perfect application
of the powerful
on-device processing
of your Android Things device
to really add intelligence
to that device.
Next, I'm going to talk
about Google Cloud platform
and how using Google
Cloud platform,
you can train, visualize,
and take action
on your devices in the field.
Finally, I'm going to touch on
the Google Assistant and all
the amazing use
cases that you can
get when you integrate the
Google Assistant on Android
Things.
Before I dive into
these services,
I want to quickly go
over Android Things.
So, Android Things is based
on a system on module design.
This means that we work really
closely with our silicon
partners to bring you modules
which you can place directly
into your IoT devices.
Now, these modules
are such that it's
economical to put them
in devices when you're
making millions of devices or
if you have a very small run,
or if you're just
prototyping a device.
So earlier today, we
actually had a session
specifically on going from
prototype to production
on Android Things, which can
give you more detail about how
it's feasible to do all this,
all the hardware design,
and bring your device to
production on Android Things.
The Android Things
operating system
is then placed on
top of these modules.
So Android Things
is a new vertical
of Android built
for IoT devices.
Since we work so closely
with our silicon partners,
we're able to maintain
these modules in new ways.
It allows these devices to be
more secure and updateable.
Also, since it's an
Android vertical,
you get all the
Android APIs they're
used to for Android development
as well as the developer tools
and the Android ecosystem.
In addition, on
Android Things we've
added some new APIs such
as peripheral iO and user
drivers that allow you
to control the hardware
on your device in new ways.
We've also added support
for a zero display
build for IoT devices
without a screen.
But really the key piece of
Android Things, I believe,
is the services on top.
Because of the API surface
that Android Things provides,
it makes it much
easier for Google
to put our services on
top of Android Things.
I say endless possibilities here
because not only does Google
already support all
the services I'm
going to walk you through
today, but any services
that Google makes in the future
will be much more portable
on Android Things because
of this API surface.
So now, let's start diving
into some of these services.
Let's talk about Google
Play services and all
the useful tools
that it provides.
Google Play services
gives you access
to a suite of tools, some
of which you see here.
So you get things like
the mobile vision APIs,
which allow you to leverage the
intelligence in your Android
camera to identify
people in an image
as well as faces and
their expressions.
You also get the nearby
APIs, which lets you--
when you have two
devices near each other--
allows those devices to
interact with each other
in interesting ways.
You get all the Cast
APIs, which lets you
from your Android device
cast to a cast enabled device
somewhere else.
Next, you get all the
location services,
which lets you
query things like,
what are the cafes near me
and what are their hours.
You also get the
Google Fit APIs,
which allow you to attach
sensors and accelerometers
to your device
and then visualize
this data as steps or other
activities in interesting ways.
Finally, you get
Firebase, which we'll
talk about more in a minute.
Some of you might know
about CTF certification
and how CTF certification
is a necessary step in order
to get these Google
Play services.
With Android Things, because
of our hardware model
that I just talked
about, these modules
actually come pre-certified.
So they're all
pre-CTF certified,
meaning Google Play Services
will work right out of the box.
You have to do
absolutely no work
to get these Google Play
services on your Android Things
device.
We also have, for
Android Things,
a custom IoT variant of
Google Play services.
Now I actually think this
is a pretty big deal.
This allows us to make Google
Play services more lightweight
by taking out things like
phone specific UI elements
and game libraries
that we don't think
are relevant for IoT devices.
We also give you a
signed out experience
of Google Play services.
So, no unauthenticated APIs
because these just aren't
relevant for many IoT devices.
So now, let's dive into Firebase
in a little bit more detail.
I'm going to walk you through
one of our code samples.
So this is the code sample for
a smart doorbell using Firebase.
It involves one of
our supported boards,
as well as a button
and a camera.
So I'm going to walk you
through this diagram.
On the left, you see
a user interacting
with the smart doorbell.
What happens is, they press the
button on the smart doorbell
and the camera takes
a picture of them.
On the right,
there's another user
who, in their
Android phone, they
can use an app to connect
to a Firebase database that
can retrieve that
image in real time.
So how does this work?
When you press the button
on the smart camera,
the camera takes
a picture of you.
Then, using the
Android Firebase SDK,
which uses the Google
Play services APIs
all on the device,
it sends this image
to the Firebase
database in the cloud.
The user on the
other end can then
use the exact same Google Play
services and Android Firebase
SDK on their phone to connect
to this Firebase database
and retrieve that image.
In our code sample, we
also send this image
to the Cloud Vision APIs to
get additional annotations
about what's in the image.
So these annotations could be
something like, in this image
there is a person
holding a package.
So that can give you additional
context about what's going on.
It's pretty cool.
If you actually go and build
this demo, you can see.
When you press the button and it
takes a picture, in less than a
second the picture will appear.
And then a few seconds
later, after the image
is propagated through
the Cloud Vision APIs,
the annotations
will appear as well.
So to really show
you how this works,
I'm going to walk through
some of the code that
pushes this data to Firebase.
So the first line
you see here is just
creating a new
door ring instance
that we're going to use
in our Firebase database.
Then, all we need to do
to make this data appear
in our Firebase database is
set the appropriate fields
of our door ring instance.
So here you can see in
the highlighted portion,
we're setting the time stamp
and the image fields so that--
with the server time
stamp and the image URL--
and then this image as
well as the timestamp
will appear in our
Firebase database
to be retrieved by the
user on the other side.
As I mentioned in
our code sample,
we also send our images
to the Cloud Vision APIs
to get those annotations.
So, we do that by calling
the Cloud Vision APIs
and then simply setting
the appropriate field
for those annotations so
that that additional context
will appear as well for
the user on the other end.
So, Firebase is one of the
many Google Play services
that you get with
Android Things.
But in the interest of
time, I can't talk about
all the Google Play services.
So instead, I want to
move on to TensorFlow.
We really think that TensorFlow
is the perfect application
for the on device processing
of your Android Things device.
So, as you've heard from some
of the previous talks on Android
Things, Android
Things is not really
well suited if you're just
making a simple sensor.
To fully utilize the
Android Things platform,
it should be doing more.
There should be some
intelligence on this device.
You might wonder, though,
if you're making an internet
connected device--
an IoT device--
why do you actually need
this on device processing?
There's actually
several reasons why
this could be really important.
One reason has to
do with bandwidth.
If, for example, you're
making a camera that's
counting the number
of people in a line
and you just care
about that number,
by only propagating
out that number
you save huge
amounts on bandwidth
by not needing to send
the image anywhere.
The second reason for
on device processing
has to do with when you have
intermittent connectivity.
So if your device is
only sometimes connected
to the internet, for it
to be really functional
it needs to have on
device processing for when
it's offline.
The next reason for
on device processing
has to do with the principle
of least privilege.
So if you, again, had that
camera where all you care about
is the number of people
standing in a line,
by the principle
of least privilege
you should only be
propagating that number
even if you trust the other
and where you're sending it.
There's also some
regulatory reasons
where this could be
important for your use case.
The final reason for
device processing
has to do with real
time applications.
So if you're, for
example, making
a robot that has to navigate
through an environment,
you want to have on
device processing
so if something comes
in front of that robot,
you'll be able to
react to the situation.
Again, I want to mention that we
have a code lab for TensorFlow
and Android Things.
So you can try it out in the
code lab area or at home.
But to really show you
TensorFlow in action,
I actually want to do a
live demo so we can really
see that it works.
So what I have here--
it's a pretty simple setup.
We have one of our
supported boards, which
is a Raspberry Pi in this case,
as well as a button, a camera,
and a speaker.
The button's here on top.
The camera is actually located
in this little Android head's
eye.
So it's in its eye right there.
And then the speaker's
in its mouth.
So what's going to happen
is, when I press the button,
the camera will take a picture.
That image is then sent through
a TensorFlow model located
locally on the device.
And then the speaker will
then say what that TensorFlow
model thinks it saw.
So for you here today,
I have various dog
breeds because locally on
this TensorFlow model, I have
what's called the
Inception Model.
Now the Inception Model is
a model provided by Google
that's able to identify
thousands of objects, including
dog breeds.
So let's see if it can do it.
I just need to line
up the image and--
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
I see a Dalmatian.
SAM BEDER: All right.
So for those of
you couldn't see--
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Deserves an applause.
It is, in fact, a dalmatian.
But let's do it one more time
to show you that it, you know,
can do more than
just one dog breed.
So this time I have
a French bulldog.
All right.
Line it up again.
Hope for the best.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hey,
that looks like me.
Just kidding.
I see a French bulldog.
[APPLAUSE]
SAM BEDER: All right.
Yeah.
Good job, little guy.
So as I mentioned, this is
all running totally locally.
So this is not connected
to the internet at all,
and since this is battery
powered, it's totally portable.
So I think that
this example really
shows you some of the power
you can get with TensorFlow.
So now, let's actually
walk through some
of the code that makes
this integration possible.
This first page, as you
can see, is pretty simple.
And this just shows us loading
up the appropriate TensorFlow
library to be used
by our device.
The first thing I
want you to note here
is that we're actually only
loading the same libraries
as is used by Android.
So, all the TensorFlow
code that works on Android
will also work on
Android Things.
All of the samples
that you already
have on Android for TensorFlow
you can import immediately
to Android Things.
The second thing
I want you to note
is that here we're
actually only loading
in the inference
libraries of TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is basically composed
of two sets of libraries.
There's training, which is
where you give it thousands
of images along with labels--
so you can make that model that
can make those predictions.
And then there's the
inference libraries,
where you're using that model
that you trained to actually
make those predictions.
So now, let's go through some
of the core functionality
to actually do
those predictions.
So these are the steps to
actually run input data
through a TensorFlow model.
The first method you see
there, the feed method,
is where you're actually
loading in your input data.
So we have three arguments.
There's the input
layer name, which
is simply that first layer
of your TensorFlow model
where you're going to
put your input data.
Next, there's tensor dimensions
which simply describes
the structure of
your input layer
so you can understand what's
going into your model.
Then you have
image pixels, which
is the actual input
data which you are
going to make predictions on.
So here in our case, since we're
taking a picture, of course
the input data is pixels.
But this same type
of TensorFlow model
will work across many use cases.
So if instead you had just
sensor data or a combination
of sensor data and
camera data, you
could use the same type
of TensorFlow model
and it would still work.
So the next slide, the
actual highlighted portion,
is where the actual
work gets done.
So we call it the run method--
to actually run this input data
through our TensorFlow model
to get that prediction
on the other side.
So here, we just need to
provide the output layer
where we want the data to go.
Finally, we need to fetch
our data so we can use it.
So we call it Fetch along
with an output array
to store our data.
Now, this output
array is composed
of elements that correspond
to the confidence
that an object is what
we saw in the image.
So in our first example,
we predicted dalmatian.
That means that the element
with highest confidence
was that that
corresponded to dalmatian.
You could actually do a
little bit more nuanced things
with these results.
So for example, if
there's two results that
both were highly
confident, you could say,
I think it's one of
these two things.
And if there were no results
above a certain threshold
of confidence, you
could say, I don't
know what's in this image.
So even once you have your
output of confidences,
you can do a little bit extra
depending on your use case.
So as I mentioned, this demo
is running completely locally.
But I think that
there's actually
more interesting things that
we can do once we also connect
devices like this to the cloud.
So next, I want to
talk about Google Cloud
Platform and specifically
Cloud IoT Core.
So Cloud IoT Core
is a new offering
that we're announcing here
at iO that's specifically
for connecting IoT devices
to the Google Cloud Platform.
Now, the Google Cloud Platform
has a number of services.
You can do things like
MQTT protocol support.
MQTT is a lightweight
protocol that's
used for communications as well
as many industrial purposes.
Cloud IoT Core is also
a 100% managed service.
This means you get things
like automatic load balancing
and resource pre-provisioning.
You can connect one device to
Cloud IoT Core or a million
devices, and all these things
still work the same way.
There's also a
global access point,
which means that no matter
what region your device is in,
it can use the
same configurations
and connect to the
same Google Cloud.
Cloud IoT Core also comes
with a Device Manager
that can allow you to interact
with your devices in the field.
So you get things
like the ability
to configure individual devices
that you have in the field,
as well as control
those devices,
set up alerts, and set up
role level access controls.
Role level access controls
could be something
like allowing one user to be
able to have read and write
access over a set of devices,
and then another user
could only have read access
or a subset of those devices.
So as I mentioned,
Cloud IoT Core
also connects you
to all the benefits
of Google Cloud Platform.
This diagram shows you
a bunch of the benefits
that Google Cloud
Platform provides.
And I'm not going to
go through all of them,
but just to point out a few.
You get things like
BigQuery and BigData
that allow you to input all
the data that you're gathering
from your Android Things devices
and then visualize and query
over that data.
You also get CloudML, to make
even more complicated machine
learning models based on all
the data you've collected
using the power of the cloud.
Finally, you get all
the analytics tools
that Google Cloud
Platform provides,
to visualize and set
up alerts on your data
and take action on the
devices you have in the field.
So to understand these
analytics a little bit better,
I'm going to go
through one more demo.
So this demo is actually running
live in our sandbox area.
And this is just a
screenshot of it working.
What we've done
here is we've set up
a bunch of
environmental stations
running on Android
Things and spread them
around Mountain View campus.
Now, these
environmental stations
have a bunch of
sensors on them, things
like humidity sensor,
temperature sensor, air
pressure sensor, luminosity
sensor, and motion detection.
And then we're able to aggregate
all this data in the cloud
by connecting it through
a Cloud IoT Core.
So on the left, you can
see some of the data
from some of these devices
they were able to aggregate.
We can also see
average temperatures
and other analytics on our data.
We can also dive into
one specific device
to really see more
data on what's
going on with that device
as well as more time series
data on how that device
has performed over time.
You might notice, though,
that this demo shows you
really well that you can connect
these devices to Google Cloud.
But it doesn't really utilize
the on device processing
that I talked about
with my TensorFlow demo.
So next, I want to go over
a few more examples that
show you these two
services working together.
Because when you combine
TensorFlow and Google Cloud
Platform, I think you can
do some really amazingly
powerful things.
So my first example
kind of extends
this environmental station demo
that I just walked you through.
Imagine instead of just putting
these environmental stations
around, we actually
connected them
to a smart vending machine.
We were then able
to use all the input
data from our
environmental station
to have a machine learning
model using TensorFlow running
locally on this device.
You could predict things
like supply and demand
based on that vending
machine's environment,
and then optimize
when this vending
machine would be restocked.
You could also connect
all of your vending
machines to the cloud and do
even more complicated analysis
on those vending machines.
You could do inventory
analysis to figure out
which items are performing
best in which environments,
and you could also do even
better prediction models
based on all the data
you're collecting.
This is actually
a perfect example
to do what we call
federated learning.
So, federated learning is when
we have multiple machines that
are all able to learn
locally, but based
on those local learning
we can aggregate
that data to make an even
better machine learning
model in the cloud.
So here, you can imagine having
one vending machine in a school
and another vending
machine in a stadium,
and both vending machines would
have very personalized models
based on their environment.
But they would also both
benefit from each other
by aggregating their
data in the cloud.
This is also a good
example that shows
you can do interesting things
without a camera just using
sensor data.
But my next example goes
over a camera use case
because I think that cameras are
perfect applications for doing
some of this on
device processing.
So imagine you have
a grocery store.
And the grocery
store puts up cameras
to count the number of
people standing in line.
This camera would use
a TensorFlow model
that's locally able to
count that number of people
in the image and propagate
that number to the cloud.
You could use this data to open
the optimal number of registers
at any given time
so you never have
to wait in line at the
grocery store again.
With all of your
aggregated data,
you could also do more
complicated machine
learning models.
You could predict
how many people
you should staff at your
grocery store on any given day.
You could also see how
optimal each grocery
store is performing
and the differences
between grocery stores.
This could even be
useful for the shoppers--
the end users.
You can imagine
making a mobile app
where, at home, you can check
how long the grocery store
line is so that you
never are frustrated
by having to wait in line
because you'll know in advance
what the situation will be.
The next use case
I want to go over
brought in this camera
example a little bit more
and applies it to an
industrial use case.
So imagine with a factory
that, let's say, makes pizzas.
And we add a camera that's
able to do quality control
to increase both the
quality and the efficiency
for this industrial application.
I should note that we
have another talk that's
specifically on enterprise
use cases on Android Things.
So you should
listen to that talk
if you want to know
more about what's
possible on Android
Things for some
of these industrial
applications.
So in this case, we would
have a TensorFlow model
that's locally able to learn how
to accept and reject pizzas by,
for example, counting the number
of toppings of each pizza.
So as we see some of
these pizzas go by,
most of them we'll see will have
six tomatoes and five olives.
And so they're accepted.
But then soon, we'll
come to one-- this one--
that one-- that has
too many tomatoes--
too few tomatoes--
and too few olives.
Sorry.
Too few tomatoes
and too many olives.
So we reject that pizza.
We could also
propagate this data
to the cloud to do more
analysis such as track
our throughput and flag
if our error rate goes
above a certain
threshold and we want
to do a manual check
on our machines.
There's one more use
case I want to go over
that uses machine learning
in a slightly different way.
So that's going to be
reinforcement learning applied
to an agricultural use case.
So imagine we have
a field that has
a bunch of moisture
sensors in the ground,
as well as sprinklers.
And these are all
connected to a central hub
running Android Things.
Now, this Android
Things hub could
do some machine
learning to optimize
exactly what the output
of when and how much
water each sprinkler
should output
to optimize our crop growth.
You may have heard of DeepMind.
Sundar actually mentioned
it in his keynote
as a company at
Alphabet that recently
made AlphaGo, which beat the
best go player in the world.
Now, this used
reinforcement learning
in really powerful ways.
And I think that
reinforcement learning
is an amazing tool that could
also be used on Android Things
really well.
With reinforcement learning, you
could discover some nuanced use
cases, such as--
imagine your hill
had a hill on it.
In that case, you
may actually want
to water the crops at
the bottom of the hill
less than those at
the top of the hill
because the sprinklers
at the top of the hill
might have runoff
water that'll add
the extra water to the crops
at the bottom of the hill.
So Android Things
makes integrations
like these really
seamless, and provides you
the tools to do anything
that you imagine.
And I think that using things
like TensorFlow and cloud
together can also do some really
amazing use cases that you
can't do with just one.
Combining these services could
do so much more for your device
and for your end users.
There's one more service I
want to talk about today,
and that's the Google Assistant.
So Android Things supports
the Google Assistant SDK.
Now, there is a huge
number of use cases
that we think the
Assistant can do for you.
It allows you to connect to
all the knowledge of Google
as well as allows you to control
the devices in your home.
Again, we have a
code lab that goes
over getting Android Things to
work with the Google Assistant.
So you can do it at home or you
can do it in our sandbox area.
We also partnered
with AIY, which
is a group at Google
that makes kits
for do it yourself artificial
intelligence makers.
And so what you see on
the screen here is the kit
they recently released--
the voice kit-- that is
one of the easiest ways
that you can get started
with Android Things
working with the
Google Assistant.
Before I end my
talk today, I want
to go over one more
feature of Android Things,
and that's the Android
Things Developer Console.
The Android Things
Developer Console
brings all these
services together.
It's our new Developer
Portal, which
we're going to
release soon, that
lets you add all these services
to a device in a really
simple way.
The key with the Android
Things developer console
is customization.
You get ultimate control
of exactly what services
will go on your device when
using the Android Things
Developer Console.
You also get device
management and updates.
So this Allows you to
create your projects
as well as upload your own
APKs for your own device
functionality and push
those feature updates
to your devices in the field.
The Android Things
Developer Console
is also where you'll get
all the updates from Google.
So these are the
security updates
and the feature updates that
will make your devices secure.
Now, since you get total control
with the Developer Console
you get to control
which updates you take
and exactly when these
updates push out.
But I believe that the
customization of The Developer
Console gives you the control
to really create anything
that you can imagine, unlocking
this unlimited potential
of what we think is
possible of Android Things,
especially when combined
with Google services.
So to summarize,
Android Things gives you
that platform that makes
hardware development feasible.
It gives you all
the Android APIs
to make your development
process easy,
combined with this
system on module design
to make it quick and
economical to make a prototype
and also bring that
device to production.
But the services
on top, I believe,
are the huge factor that
allows you to really
innovate and enhance your
device as well as bring
new features to your users.
So we have Google
Play services, which
gives you this suite of tools
like the mobile vision APIs,
location services,
as well as Firebase.
You get TensorFlow, which
uses the powerful on device
processing of your
Android Things
device to add that
intelligence to your device.
You also get Google Cloud
Platform, and specifically
Cloud IoT Core to
connect your device
to the even greater
intelligence of the cloud.
And finally, you get
the Google Assistant,
the latest and
greatest in Google's
personal assistant technology.
All these services, and any
that come in the future,
will fit on top
of Android Things
to unlock this potential
of your device.
I want to leave you today
with my call to action.
We have a huge
number of sessions
on Android Things this year,
as well as demos and code
labs for you to learn
more about what's
possible on Android Things.
We also have a
developer site where
you can visit to download the
latest Android Things image
and start making your idea.
I encourage you to add some
of these Google services
to your device to see how
powerful they really can
be, and then tell us about it.
Join our developer community,
where thousands of people
are already asking questions,
sharing their ideas,
sharing their prototypes,
and getting feedback.
Again, I'm Sam Beder.
And I look forward to hearing
about all the amazing devices
that you're building on
Android Things that integrate
these powerful Google services.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]